vous
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]
il est classé
les sentait bon
j'ai tout aimé
car mais quand même
je veux plus jamais bon
en somme
[Musique]
on
les ce qui brille au milieu doute se
montre chambre qui vivait à
à chaque seconde je m'en fous de la
vérité je suis ses esprits étriqués
mais clip they
flipo lvt la réalité la soirée madame
est ce que j'attends par le soleil
quand on l'attend pas plus jamais je me
sens vivant
faudrait pas pour autant d'envié anodin
avant de parler d'art or les verts s'en
servir
les raisons
g
je veux plus jamais
c'était
les places en servez
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé
kate anvers je veux plus jamais bon
m
c'était
ce sera bien
la patte gauche le pays si paris
je suis sorti j'ai pris la porte
dauphine tout émeutier de la veille dans
une berline 4 4 gb ski tous les 22
dans ma tête c'est la fête comme de
gauche
je peux pas taper bébés y ait du monde
c'est le revendeur je dois fermer le
pommeau temps qu'itil ani dans 10 ans
tous les deux dans
le soir julie on ferait bon
j'attendrai
non
soit
[Musique]
non
m
gfr
j'ai soulevé
je veux plus jamais pas
c'était moi
à
les verts s'en servait
mais il est vrai
m
[Musique]
ne demandez jamais
c'était lui
c'est bien
ma vie
on sait là
[Musique]
à